spécial de journée en direct d'Ottawa à
l'occasion de la présentation du budget
fédéral 202324 par le ministre des
Finances Christophe Freeland qu'on a le
plaisir de recevoir sur notre plateau
Madame le Ministre bonsoir alors vous
avez annoncé aujourd'hui ce grand plan
sur l'économie propre sur les
technologies propres 80 milliards de
dollars sur 10 ans est-ce que c'est la
réponse à l'inflation rédaction hack de
Joe Biden partiellement mais on ne doit
pas manquer que le Canada a commencé en
pendant la campagne électorale en 2015
on a dit que l'économie et
l'environnement sont liés et on a
commencé en mettant une prise sur la
pollution on a affaire beaucoup des
investissements dans la transition verte
avant de ses budgets a fait beaucoup
dans le budget du 2021 de 2022 dans
l'unité de l'automne mais vous avez
raison que le plan économique des
États-Unis
a changé la situation concurrentielle
dans le monde les ténériens ont mis
beaucoup de l'argent sur la table de
dollars est-ce que on a l'impression
qu'on est à la remorque quand même des
Américains parce que Joe Biden a annoncé
cela et là nous tout à coup on arrive
avec ce projet là il y a beaucoup de
gens qui vous faisaient pression en
disant pour l'innovation pour la
compétitivité du Canada vous devez
annoncer ce plan que vous avez annoncé
finalement aujourd'hui mais pas dans le
dernier budget ni dans le précédent
d'accord je pense que vraiment on doit
être confiante que c'est le Canada qui a
commencé avec les grandes
investissements et avec les règles
importantes
en même temps je suis d'accord avec vous
que on ne peut pas
il y a une compétition internationale
pour les capitaux privés et avec ce
budget le Canada vraiment sera
qui choisissent de venir au Canada
qu'aux États-Unis par exemple pour
investir pour développer des
technologies propres après cette je
pense que non je pense qu'on va vraiment
gagner on ne va pas gagner tous les
investissements dans le monde
nous sommes seulement 40 000 Canadiens
excusez-moi 40 millions mais je pense
qu'on peut être confiante que le Canada
va gagner notre juste par à cause de ces
investissements mais on a une autre
avantage qui est considérable et c'est
les investissements qu'on fait dans
notre filiale sociale et c'est vraiment
à une effet économique aussi
j'ai parlé avec une entreprise
canadienne elle a des usines au Canada
et des usines aux États-Unis aux
États-Unis
25% des employés sont malades chaque
jour au Canada c'est seulement 8 pour
100 et c'est à cause de tous les
investissements qu'on fait pas seulement
dans les soins de santé et vous savez
que je pense que les investissements
dans les garderies sont très importants
aussi
dentaires également dans la santé ce qui
fait que les dépenses augmentent
continuent d'augmenter le déficit
augmente finalement parce qu'on avait
prévu un déficit de moindre la dette
augmente cette année par rapport aux
produits intérieur brut à un moment ou
une récession arrive est-ce que la
situation budgétaire du Canada se
détériore non
et je vais un peu préciser ce que vous
avez juste dire
parce que le déficit de cette année va
diminuer
avec le déficit de l'année passée parce
que vous mettez la bonification du
crédit TPS dans l'exercice de 20223 si
vous l'aviez mis dans 23 24 le déficit
aurait monté et quoi qu'il en soit le
déficit ce que je veux vous dire surtout
c'est que le déficit est plus important
que ce que vous aviez prévu dans la mise
à jour économique
vous avez raison mais les projections
économiques sont détériorées aussi et
j'ai juste parlé avec jimmigion pour
préciser parce qu'il a dit que les
projections économiques ne sont pas des
théories ce n'est pas exact dans
l'énoncé économique de l'OTAN on a prévu
une croissance cette année de
0,7%. maintenant les économistes du
secteur privé prévu une croissance
seulement de 0,3 personnes ça a une
effet mais la chose que je veux assurer
vous et tous les écouteurs c'est que
vraiment on a une plante responsable de
côté budgétaire le déficit diminue cette
année et va continuer de diminuer et
aussi je pense que c'est important
il n'y a plus de retour à l'équilibre
budgétaire je n'ai pas fait accent on
entend
sur le déficit zéro qu'on a prévu
c'était
une effet
créé par les projections des économistes
et on a mis dans les insectes
aussi une scénario plus pessimiste mais
l'autre chose que je voudrais dire qui
est important
pour rassurer les Canadiens c'est pour
moi une chose très importante c'est
préserver notre côte de crédit triple
alors je fais beaucoup d'attention à
ceux qui font des autres pays avec une
côte de crédit triple
on aura cette année une déficit plus bas
que le déficit des États-Unis et de
l'Allemagne les autres pays du G7 avec
une contreditive et une déficit plus bas
que l'Australie et les Pays-Bas qui ont
aussi une contre distributeur alors je
veux dire que dans le contexte
international ça va et quand vous avez
dit avec les économistes on a augmenté
les impôts pour payer pour ces
investissements les impossibles sur les
plus riches et on doit économiser sur ce
que sur ce que le gouvernement dépense
alors
où est responsable mais la dette
augmente quand même il n'y a pas de
déficit zéro on dirait que ça fait
depuis 2015 les libéraux sont à l'aise
avec le fait de ne pas jamais être à
l'équilibre budgétaire
comment ça s'explique ça pourquoi c'est
comme ça pour nous la tendance qui est
importante c'est du démontrer que on a
une situation stable qu'on a et pour
nous ce qui démontre cela c'est notre
code de crédit triple A c'est que quand
on regarde les chiffres les déficits
vont diminuer chaque année et la dette
va diminuer si on regarde le cadre
budgétaire la dette diminue et c'est
important dernière question parce que je
dois vous laisser partir est-ce qu'il
est clair pour vous qu'en 2023 le Canada
sera en récession
moi je n'ai pas une boule de cristal
personnel mais comme vous avez constaté
avec les économistes avec les qui vous
avez juste parlé les économistes du
secteur privé
qui ont fait les prévisions quand on
montre dans le budget pensent que on
aura une croissance dans cette année de
0,3% pour tout l'année mais pour les
premiers 3 trimestres on aura une petite
à diminuation du du l'économie
je pense que une élément et on verra on
est dans une économie
qu'on n'a pas connaît à jamais avant à
cause de covid on a des phénomènes qui
sont nouvelles pour tous
jusqu'à maintenant et aux États-Unis il
y a la même chose
l'économie se ralentit mais en même
temps le niveau de chômage et
n'est pas élevé alors on verra ce qui se
passe mais je veux aussi rassurer tous
les Canadiens que
il y a beaucoup d'incertitudes dans
l'économie mondiale le Canada est prête
à appuyer les Canadiens dans tous les
scénarios et si je peux dire une chanson
très très vite je veux juste dire que
c'est une budget qui investit dans les
Canadiens dans la portabilité dans la
santé mais surtout dans la croissance
économique on tire des investissements
nécessaires sont l'économie propre c'est
un plaisir de vous accueillir merci de
vous voir en personne merci
avec nous ce soir